on the first day
of the final month of 2020 suspension
cables forming
part of the iconic arecibo telescope
snapped
releasing an instrument platform as
heavy as 2
000 grand pianos
the thunder of its collapse reverberated
across the karst landscape of puerto
rico
even those unfamiliar with the
telescope's name
might know it by sight the dramatic size
of arecibo
the largest telescope in the world for
more than 50 years
inspired scenes in movies like goldeneye
and contact
burning its image into the public's
consciousness
for radio astronomers the telescope was
far more than a backdrop
it was a living tool for science its
career began
as a u.s defense project tucked into a
sinkhole to shield it from radio
interference
as it scanned the ionosphere for missile
trails
in 1969 the national science foundation
took over our sibo
and in 1974 replaced the dish's wire
mesh surface
with 38 000 aluminum panels so it could
operate at higher frequencies
one of the telescope's antenna called
the 430 megahertz line feed
bounced radar beams off the ionosphere
from its perch
on a 900 ton platform which hung 137
meters above the dish
suspended by cables attached to three
support towers
the dish had a spherical shape unlike
the usual parabola
so arecibo could view areas of sky not
directly overhead
to point at these off zenith objects
receivers
underneath the platform could be moved
using an azimuth arm
the drawback of the spherical shape was
that it focused incoming rays into a
line
decades later engineers installed the
gregorian
dome which housed additional reflectors
to focus rays to a point
making the telescope more flexible the
telescope can claim some important
discoveries
of 20th and 21st century astronomy
it revealed the first indirect evidence
of gravitational waves
mapped venus's cloud veiled surface and
detected the first planets outside of
our solar system
the telescope also bounced radio waves
off planets
and asteroids heated plasma in the
earth's atmosphere to create artificial
auroras
and beamed a message to the stars
[Music]
but as its achievements mounted age
began to creep up on arecibo
a moist tropical climate hurricanes and
earthquakes
all took a toll in the 1970s
to combat water seeping into the cables
and causing corrosion
caretakers painted the cables and
installed air pumps to keep them dry
the gregorian dome also added weight to
the structure
so engineers had to tack on auxiliary
cables to support the instrument
platform
one of these cables was the first to
fail leading up to the collapse
it's possible arecibo didn't receive all
the carrot needed
in recent years as the national science
foundation
turned its attention to newer astronomy
projects it reduced its funding for the
aging telescope
a panel of experts has proposed building
a new
more capable telescope in arecibo stead
but its 400 million dollar price tag
may meet roadblocks
[Music]
if funded an expansive telescope project
would provide a boost for puerto rico
which is reeled in the wake of several
natural disasters
including 2017's hurricane maria
a new scope might also steer the next
generation of astronomers
both in the tropics and around the globe
toward another half
century of profound discovery
[Music]
you